yes it is wild 94 one minute bootleg
camp here we got a special guest in
studio I met her out in New York at the
sin Awards she got a crazy new record
man with a Jeremiah Natalie la rose Yeah
right is it like a drunken Spanish 20 oh
yeah I wasn't there was a nice little
are you head there weren't a floor you
know so we got ready for the Hispanic
exactly my name is Dutch though it's
Dutch yeah yo so you grew up in
Hamsterdam I read was reading yes I did
born a race does that automatically make
you a pyit no it doesn't but you you
definitely did you / take out there I
mean it's like you know it's like
drinking out there right no comment no
comment anything we're dealing with a
pipe oh I don't do it though no I'm just
playing um so I read to that you of
course if people don't know you are
signed the flo rida yes yeah of course
has got a historical history with having
hit records you know gigantic record
some of the movie songs ever you walked
up to a man like an SPS after party and
introduce yourself yeah aight i'll
explain that to us man tell us that
story how you been flo rida and how
everything came to be I was basically on
a mission that day I heard Flo Rida was
performing and I was like I need to meet
him so I'm i found a backstage after his
performance and I basically said I want
to work with you and I think he was like
ok these girl this girl got some guts
right and that's when he invited me to
the studio and he heard some of my music
and I showed him some dance videos
because I'm a dancer ok and after that
he invited me on the road I started
performing with him outside the country
so that was really really exciting for
me and and after that he signed me as
his artist how did you get backstage in
the first place did you have to like
finagle your way back there um yeah
there was somebody um that somebody I
knew
and who knew that I really liked was
working hard right my music and I really
had a dream so he was like okay I'm
gonna help you get back there and let me
fix some things so that's what he did
and we found him backstage now I know
the new song samples from Whitney
Houston it was like a big artist sample
yeah was that like a hard thing to get
cleared too heavy but was there any sort
of communication or dialogue between you
guys on what needs estate or um it
wasn't very easy but eventually we got
it cleared and I'm just so happy that
you know I got the inspiration from her
you know it's a great melody the lyrics
are great so I'm just so thankful for
Whitney yeah for people who haven't
heard your music or are familiar with
you if you had to compare yourself to
you know somebody or some people that
you're influenced by who do you say that
you know you are some artists that you
grab from and how you give some people
like a little summary of who natalie
larosa's musically well growing up I
listened a lot to Mariah Carey I'm
Whitney I love love Stevie Wonder
performance-wise Michael Jackson Janet
Jackson or like huge inspirations and
right now who inspires me a lot is
Beyonce too and so I just love I love
80's music 90s I love a little bit of
everything I love jazz music too so ya
know do you have the album done are you
working on an album I mean you just
worry about the single right now what's
going on um right now we're working on
getting the video done it's probably
next week we're shooting it next week
and further we're working on an EP I
hope it's going to come out soon we're
still recording as we split okay yeah uh
you are very beautiful most people are
gonna watch this interview be like damn
let me follow her on Instagram so I get
me thinking like forty two week old
photos are you single yes I am you are
single main focus is music right now
nice are you prepared to be a bunch of
when you get really famous you realize
you're going to be in a ton of single
male spank banks and married male spank
banks oh yeah
are you prepared for that I'm not sure
that's a good thing that's a good thing
hey a bunch of dudes bank makes a ninja
papi oh she's like I don't know what's
going on what the hell is fake yeah I
really don't know what it means banking
is like okay for example like my spank
bank is like Nicki Minaj tanasha is in
the spank bank beyonce's old like she's
never leaving always been she's okay
it's like you know when guys uh how do I
put this without I think I understand
guys rub one out they got their little I
go to roster in their head okay I think
one day you're gonna not one day or it
might be someone spent way okay well
that's that's a big compliment is
something you're very beautiful I'm
missing you get one famous Young's asus
a good comes along with it um another
thing like when it comes to being like
from overseas you know I feel like a lot
of artists they get real pocket overseas
like it seems like it's easier for some
people to get their career started over
there and then come over here is that
something that you've done over there
like are you kind of already established
in Europe hmm not really because I
actually left my country the Netherlands
right um to do my music career so I
hadn't really started my musical career
in Amsterdam because I was dancing first
so it actually all started here in the
US but what I think is great is that
both the US and amsterdam showing me
love right now like they're playing and
over in my country too in here in the
radio so for me that's just you know
really overwhelming and fun what is
divided difference like growing up in
amsterdam and now that you're in the
states all the time what is like the
main difference to you like as far as
like the United States versus over there
been to Amsterdam I want to go obviously
it's a different energy um the Dutch
people are very down-to-earth free just
you know not a lot of worry or pressure
these rooms hi matter is that true um
the energy here in the states is really
high and that's why that's one of the
reasons I moved here because everybody
is fighting for a dream yeah fighting to
accomplish something and I am motivated
by that yes motivation for sure yeah
that's up well the new song is crazy how
about you introduce your new single got
a new record with Jeremiah this nuts and
we've hit a couple times go ahead and
talk in that for us hi guys i'm neta
lela rose and i want to introduce you to
my song somebody featuring Jeremih let's
do it